one of the things you've mentioned
is um the space of all possible rules
that we
kind of discussed a little bit uh that
you know there could be i guess the set
of possible rules is infinite
right well so here's here's the big sort
of one of the conundrums that that i'm
kind of trying to deal with is let's say
we think we found
the rule for the universe and we say
here it is
you know write it down it's a little
tiny thing and then we say
gosh that's really weird why did we get
that one
right and then we're in this whole
situation because
let's say it's fairly simple how did we
come up the winners getting one of the
simple possible universe rules
why didn't we get what some incredibly
complicated rule
why do we get one of the simpler ones
and and that's a thing which you know in
the history of science
you know the whole sort of story of
copernicus
and so on was you know we used to think
the earth was the center of the universe
but now we find out it's not and we're
actually just in some you know random
corner of some random galaxy out in this
big universe there's nothing special
about
us so if we get you know universe number
317 out of all the infinite number of
possibilities
how do we get something that small and
simple right so i was very confused by
this
and it's like what are we going to say
about this how are we going to explain
this
and i thought it was might be one of
these things where you just you know you
can get it to the threshold
and then you find out its rule number
such and such and you just have no idea
why it's like that
yeah okay so then i realized it's
actually more bizarre than that
okay so we talked about multi-way graphs
we talked about this idea that you take
these underlying transformation rules on
these hyper graphs
and you apply them wherever the rule can
apply
you apply it and that makes this whole
multi-way graph of possibilities
okay so let's go a little bit weirder
let's say
that at every place not only do you
apply a particular rule
in all possible ways it can apply but
you apply all possible rules
in all possible ways they can apply as
you say
that's just crazy that's way too
complicated you're never going to be
able to conclude anything
okay however it turns out oh
that don't tell me there's some kind of
invariance yeah
yeah so what happens is and that would
be amazing
right so so this thing that you get is
this kind of rule multi-way graph this
multi-way graph that is a branching of
rules as well as a branching
of possible applications of rules this
thing has causal invariance
it's a it's an inevitable feature that
it shows causal and variance and that
means that
you can take different reference frames
different ways of slicing this thing
and they will all in some sense be
equivalent if you if you make the right
translation they will be equivalent
so okay so the the basic point here is
if that's
true that would be beautiful it is true
and it is beautiful
so you you it's not just an intuition
there's some
no no there's real mathematics behind
this and it and it's
it is it is okay so here's yes
yeah that that would be that's amazing
right so so by the way i mean the
mathematics that's connected to is the
mathematics of higher category theory
and
group voids and things like this which
i've always been afraid of but now i'm
i'm i'm finally wrapping my arms around
it but
um it's also related to it also relates
to computational complexity theory
um it's also deeply related to the p
versus np
problem and other things like this again
seems completely bizarre that these
things are connected but here's why it's
connected
the this space of all possible
okay so a turing machine very simple
model of computation
you know you just got a this tape where
you write down you know
ones and zeros or something on the tape
and you have this this rule that
says you know you you change the number
you move the head of the
on the tape etc they have a definite
rule for doing that
a deterministic turing machine just does
that deterministically given the
configuration of the tape
it will always do the same thing a
non-deterministic turing machine
can have different choices that it makes
in every step yeah
and so you know you know this stuff you
probably teach this stuff
the um it um uh
you know so a non-deterministic turing
machine has the set of branching
possibilities
which is in fact one of these multi-way
graphs and in fact
if you say imagine the extremely
non-deterministic turing machine the
turing machine
that can just do uh that takes any
possible rule at each step
that is this real multi-way graph the
set of the set of trans
the set of possible histories of that
extreme non-deterministic turing machine
is a rule multi-way graph
and your uh what term you're using rule
rule
okay so this so that i i'm trying to
think of
i'm trying to think of the space of
rules uh so these are basic
transformations
so in a turing machine it's like it says
move left
move you know if it's a one if it's a
black square
under the head move left and right a
green square
that's a rule that's a very basic rule
but i'm trying to see
the rules on the hyper graphs how rich
of the programs can they be or do they
all
ultimately just map into something
simple yeah they're all
i mean hyper graphs that's another layer
of complexity on this whole thing you
can you can think about these in
transformations of hypergraphs
but turing machines are a little bit
thicker with two machines okay right
they're a lot simpler so if you look at
these extreme non-deterministic turing
machines
you're mapping out all the possible
non-deterministic pars that the turing
machine can follow
yeah and and if you ask the question uh
can you reach
okay so so a deterministic turing
machine follows a single path
the non-deterministic turing machine
fills out this whole uh
sort of ball of possibilities and so
then
the p versus mp problem ends up being
questions about
and we haven't completely figured out
all the details of this but it's
basically
has to do with questions about the the
growth of that ball
relative to what happens with individual
paths and so on
so essentially there's a geometrization
of the p versus mp problem that comes
out of this
that's a side show okay the main the
main event here
is the statement that you can look at
this multi-way graph where the branches
correspond not just to different
applications of a single rule
but to different applications to
applications of different rules
okay and that then that when you
say i'm going to be an observer embedded
in that system
and i'm going to try and make sense of
what's going on in the system
and to do that i essentially am picking
a reference frame
and that turns out to be
well okay so the way this comes out
essentially is the reference frame you
pick
is the rule that you infer is what's
going on
in the universe even though all possible
rules are being run
although all those possible rules are in
a sense giving the same answer because
of causal and variance
but what you see will be could be
completely different if you pick
different reference frames
you essentially have a different
description language for describing the
universe
okay so how does that what does this
really mean in practice so imagine
there's us we think about the universe
in terms of space and time and we have
various kinds of description models and
so on
now let's imagine the friendly aliens
for example
right how do they describe their
universe well
you know our description of the universe
probably is affected by the fact that
you know we are about the size we are
you know meter-ish tall so to speak
we have brain processing speeds of about
the speeds we have
we're not the size of planets for
example where the speed of light really
would matter
you know in our everyday life the speed
of light doesn't really matter
everything can be you know the fact that
the speedo light is finite is irrelevant
it could as well be infinite
we wouldn't wouldn't make any difference
you know it affects the the ping times
on the internet
that's about it that's right it's about
the level of of um of how we notice the
speed of light
in our sort of everyday existence we
don't really notice it um
and so we have a way of describing the
universe that's based on
our sensory you know our senses our
uh these days also on the mathematics
we've constructed and so on
but the realization is that's not the
only way to do it
there will be completely completely
utterly incoherent descriptions of the
universe
which correspond to different reference
frames
in this sort of rule space in the royal
space that's fascinating so we're
we have some kind of reference frame in
this real space right and from that
that's why we are attributing this rule
to the universe
so in other words when we say why is it
this rule and not another
the answer is just you know shine the
light back on us so to speak
it's because of the reference frame that
we've picked in our way of understanding
what's happening in the sort of
space of all possible rules and so on
but also in the space
from this reference frame because of the
royal
the the uh the invariance
that simple that the rule on which the
universe
the with which you can run the universe
might as well be simple
yes
you